>> Hello.
Mexico will be hosting the conference of the
party 16, COP 16, in
Cancun this December.
And we are -- we want to learn from the mistake
we made in Copenhagen
really.
We are trying to bring all together, all the
countries to the table.
We want to hear all the voices.
We want to understand all the interest, in
order to reach a real
consistent, robust agreement.
Tackle climate change.
The evidence coming from the academia researching
is overwhelming.
And today all the problems that we have associated
with climate change
are effecting the lives of common citizens
around the world.
In order to tackle climate change, we need
to work together.
And we need to understand different the point
of view, the different
concerns, different interests.
Not only by developed but also developing
countries.
What we need to do is to build an economic
framework in order to start
the right economic incentives to motive and
stimulate the participation
of all countries and governments tackling
climate change.
So what we want to do is to put in actions
the response [INAUDIBLE] and
in order to under the result-based principles,
start to work against
climate change.
Many in the developing countries, we can do
a lot of things.
We in Mexico are working really hard in terms
of preventing
deforestation, reforestation areas.
We are reducing unilaterally our emissions
15 million stone by 2012
year.
And we have a commitment of 30 percent of
reduction from business as
usual by the year 2020, and 50 percent by
the year 2050.
So we are working with other countries.
We are organizing the COP 16.
It will be very difficult to reach agreement.
We must do that.
We have no more time to wait for the world.
We will be waiting for you in Cancun.
Please give us all the support coming from
the civil society, NGOs in
order to get new momentum and get a very successful
meeting of COP 16
in Cancun, Mexico.
Thank you.